do a lot of work with the Center for
social innovation here so I'm passionate
about the social sector and I appreciate
especially people like you who are
willing to volunteer time and expertise
for these organizations they're doing
important things but they can benefit
from the background that you have as a
business person and and that's a great
that's a great relationship so thank you
for doing that what I'm going to talk to
you about for a few minutes this morning
is is a set of ideas about how to make
your ideas more successful and this may
apply to the project that you're working
on we're going to talk about a
phenomenon it towards the end of the
presentation that is going to tell you
why it's gonna be really difficult even
though you have lots of expertise that
could be relevant for the organizations
that you're dealing with why it's going
to be difficult to get that message
across to people in the organizations
and in fact there's a great irony that
says that wherever in life we are good
enough to actually solve important
problems in the field we are going to be
most ineffective at communicating our
solutions to others and so I'll talk
about that I'll talk about that at the
end but basically this is a presentation
about how to make your ideas stick I
hope that it will be useful to you in
your work environment in your volunteer
activities but to get into it let me
start by talking about a fairly unusual
example of ideas sticking how many of
you have heard that statement you only
use 10% of your brain who ran this
research study all right I mean the
brain is actually a very delicate very
costly organ if you weren't only using
10% of it the rest of it would have
withered away a long time ago and if
this were true brain damage would be a
much less serious problem
you can imagine a cop show where the
police officer saying ma'am I'm sorry
your husband took a bullet to the skull
but luckily it only passed through the
90% of his brain that he wasn't using
all right this is ludicrous but it
propagates very successfully in cultures
it has a market share above I think 90%
among this very distinguished group of
people here are a few more the Great
Wall it turns out is not the only
man-made structure that is visible from
outer space
this one actually fooled me until
somebody pointed out that the Great Wall
of China is indeed very long but it's
also relatively thin so if you could see
it from outer space you could also see
any eight lane freeway in Los Angeles
Ozzy Osbourne denies biting the head off
of a live bat during the rock and roll
concert and for those of you that
remember this far back little Mikey from
the old life cereal commercials the kid
that wouldn't need anything nutritious
except for life cereal did not in fact
die from an overdose of pop rocks and
coca-cola these are all bogus stories
but I want you to think about the last
time it was important for you to get a
message across and I want you to think
about a situation where as important for
you to make an idea stick with somebody
else that means that they understood
what you were saying that they could
remember it later on and that they could
act on it it changed the way that they
thought about the world or the way that
they acted in the world so that's the
definition of sticking now there are
lots of situations where we need to make
our ideas stick and what I want to
suggest is that sometimes we aren't as
successful at sticking our important
ideas as these kind of trivial things
about you only use 10% of your brain or
ozzy osbourne in the bat those are in
some ways more successful than we are at
sticking our most important I guess
there are some complications your ideas
may need to persist so that you can walk
out of the rim and people can still
understand what you said and respond to
it later on important ideas also have to
cross boundaries you are consulting for
an organization you're coming from a
different perspective on life than the
people that you're working with
that's a boundary that your ideas have
to cross even within organizations in
Detroit the people who design cars don't
speak the same language as the people
who manufacture the cars and those
manufacturing people speak a very
different language than the
Nantz people that fund the cars and so
even within the boundaries of the single
organization there are important sub
foundries that ideas have to cross now
what I want to suggest is that there's
kind of a curious prototype for thinking
about if we want to understand how to
make our messages stick I want to
suggest that urban legends are not a bad
place to start
number one they persist over time so
that story about you only use 10% of
your brain you may think that that's a
relatively modern example of our
fascination with neuroscience I mean we
can't open up a magazine today without
seeing a picture of a brain and you know
when somebody's thinking about something
and what parts of the brain are lighting
up but it turns out that there are a set
of folklorists they have studied urban
legends like this and the earliest
example that we can find of the own you
only use 10% of your brain idea is in a
discussion of the World's Fair in 1924
in this country right so for over 80
years that idea has persisted in this
culture it turns out that urban legends
also cross boundaries and so that idea
about you only use 10% of your brain I
had the opportunity to speak to a group
of people from Malaysia a few months
back and I was a little worried about
giving this presentation because I knew
these these urban legends were
widespread in this culture but I didn't
know if they had made it to Malaysia and
so at the cocktail party before I was
talking to them I kind of was trying
some of the mountain I said have you
heard this you only use 10% of your
brain and they said oh yeah yeah we know
that one and then I tried a more obscure
one so one of the things that I
sometimes talk about is a legend that
happens in this country about picking up
a hitchhiker on a deserted road and
later on that hitchhiker vanishes under
mysterious circumstances and through a
chain of a bench you find out that the
person you picked up lived at an address
where there was a person who died on
that road 20 years before all right so
you've encountered a ghost it's a
modern-day ghost story and this is a
fairly obscure urban legend I thought
and I started telling it and they
started laughing and they said oh yeah
we know that one too
in fact in Malaysia it's well known that
if there's a hitchhiker on the road
before you pick them up you should look
to see whether their feet are touching
the ground and if their feet aren't
touching the ground you don't pick them
up which is which is a good piece of
advice
so notice notice that that's a story
that hasn't has crossed really central
cultural boundaries I mean you might not
have thought that the same idea that
captivates people's attention in North
America in the United States would
captivate people's attention in a very
different cultural setting but really
effective stories really effective
truths really effective proverbs very
often cross cultural boundaries all
right let me point out that urban
legends don't have a lot of the
advantages that some of your ideas have
they don't have newspaper coverage
advertising budgets the attention of top
management belongs newsletters or
podcast or the assistance of PR
professionals and yet they survive and
spread on their own so what I want to
give you today are six hints to make
your ideas as successful as urban
legends what I'm going to be talking
about to you is the content from a book
that's coming out in January I wrote
this with my brother Dan who's 10 years
younger so it's a bit of a family
project this is the final cover I have
copies of the book in the special
limited edition black you know black
album that I will be passing out I don't
have quite enough for the people in this
room so so let me ask that people who
are not normally around campus I know
some of your around campus I can get you
a copy later when I pass these out later
leave these for the people who aren't on
campus on a daily basis but this is
stuff that will be coming out in January
and there are six hints that we talked
about in the book urban legends are
simple unexpected concrete credible
emotional stories and if you notice
there's a little logo
in there so this is the framework for
thinking about urban legend style
success first point urban legends are
simple now it turns out that there are
another class of ideas that are not
naturally sticky they're actually
designed but they're designed for a very
complex task and they have this
characteristic of being simple if you
think about the task of making a movie
is an incredibly difficult feat if
you've ever sat there in the theater and
watch the credits scroll up at the end
of the movie there are actors and
actresses and composers and set
designers and best boys and key grips
whatever those things are so there are a
lot of different professions with
different backgrounds that have to come
together to make what is hopefully a
coherent artistic product now even
before you get permission to make a
movie there is another boundary that
your message has to cross and that's the
boundary between the artistic people who
are making the movie and the finance
people at the studios who fund the
movies and there's a word there's a
phrase in Hollywood for the kinds of
pitches that they make to get permission
to make movies and to guide the artistic
vision later on a couple of high-concept
this is a simple short description of
the movie it's very often in the form of
an analogy and that's how you make your
pitch that's how you get your money
that's how you keep people on track as
different professions are working
together towards a movie so let me give
you a test suppose that you wanted to
pitch the movie that would become alien
you want to do a really scary science
fiction movie right now in the past
those two genres were not often crossed
and when they did they ended up with
things like Godzilla eats New York which
are you know kind of science fiction or
comedy but but that's not where you're
going for you're trying to make a really
scary science fiction movie how do you
pitch what's the high concept for that
movie jaws on a spaceship all right now
that's a simple idea let me ask you some
questions about it first if you're a
finance person in Hollywood do you want
to fund this movie probably jaws was one
of the most successful movies
of all times alright so first question
down second we have two alternatives for
shillings of the completed movies one is
a is a nice pre-christmas pre holiday
season slot the other is a summer
introduction how many of you want the
pre Christmas holiday season all right
so another good decision made based on a
very simple message here's here's a more
difficult question how important is your
composure going to be for jaws on a
spaceship probably pretty I mean 83 or
so percent of the thrills and jaws were
not not seeing the shark in fact once
the shark appeared it was actually a
little bit disappointing but that bet
theme you know in the boat is on the
ocean it was dumped on don't don't don't
don't you know you need a good composer
for this movie and here's the final
master's-level question but all of you
qualified there is you need a set
designer for Jaws on a spaceship there
happens to be a former set designer for
the Star Trek television series that is
available to you in your movies has a
lot of experience with science fiction
has a lot of experience with science
fiction sets do you want the Star Trek
television design you guys are more
negative than most audiences I I would
suggest that you're right I mean there
is no lint in the Star Trek universe
everything works perfectly in the Star
Trek universe there's little doors with
all right 90% of the thrills and jaws
were the fact that they were in the
middle of this vast ocean in this
rickety boat which at any moment could
disintegrate and in fact did over the
car you know the course of the movie and
so if you've got the Star Trek designer
doing those beautiful Lindt less well
working sets that's not going to capture
the fear of being trapped on the
spaceship that itself is maybe falling
apart with a scary creature right now
notice that all of that information all
of those decisions that you just made
were made with a very simple idea it
happened to be a really important core
idea for the people who are constructing
this movie but very simple messages if
they're the right simple message
can be extraordinarily powerful now why
our simple message is important it turns
out that there's a phenomenon called
decision paralysis that all of you know
about but let me show you how important
decision paralysis can be get a group of
college students and ask them to imagine
that they have an evening already
planned so they're gonna go the library
for a couple of hours and study for some
courses they need to study for and later
on in the evening they're gonna hang out
with some prints but as they're walking
across campus to the library they see a
sign an advertisement for a speech that
very evening one evening only with a
speaker that they've always admired and
so now the choice comes do I continue on
my plan for my evening or do I go see
this once in a lifetime speaking
opportunity and what may not surprise
you is that 80% abandoned the library
abandon their friends later on and go
see this once in a lifetime speech by a
person that they've always admire now a
second group of students was asked to
simulate kind of mentally simulate a
slightly different scenario they were
also told about the library in the
evening they were also told that you
know going across campus you see a sign
for visiting speaker but right next to
that sign for this group they see
another ad in his for a foreign film
that's in very limited release right now
but has been creating a lot of buzz and
they've really been wanting to see this
and so now you've got two choices
for your evening rather than the thing
that you would have done before remember
that before
80% chose to go see the visiting speaker
so we might expect we would pick up an
additional you know 10 15 20 percent
that's going to do one of the other of
these two attractive options what
actually happens is the number of people
who do either of the two options drops
right more choices more good choices
makes us less likely to do anything
right now this is a parable for those of
you consulting on mission to your
organization's I talked to a hospital
recently who had 11
different core values now let me suggest
that when you're making in a critical
decision even though all eleven core
values are really important and really
good you are not going to know which one
to apply in this situation maybe three
you could wade through in this case two
though is substantially paralyzing
people two good options makes people
less likely to choose so back to the
simple point Southwest Airlines all of
us have seen case studies read lots of
articles about Southwest Airlines a
tremendously successful organization and
there have been claims made that I find
somewhat plausible that in the entire
history of the airline's industry
investors have lost month anybody that
has ever put money into the airline's
industry has on average lost money from
the time of the Wright brothers and and
it's kind of plausible because it's
impossible to make money in industries
where people are really passionate so
Hollywood movies are not a great place
to make investments upscale wineries are
not a good place to make investments the
Gallo region of the wine market is the
profitable region all right but
Southwest Airlines stands apart at one
point Herb Kelleher the CEO of Southwest
Airlines told a group of people and he
he said this repeatedly over his tenure
I can teach you to be CEO of Southwest
Airlines in five minutes you want to
here here it is this is one thing you
need to know Southwest is the low fare
airline that's up now here's a test for
you tracie flight attendant on the dip
the Houston to Las Vegas wide comes to
you and says you know this is kind of a
long flight and do you know what we're
serving our customers on this flight
we're serving up peanuts right how about
we put together a nice chicken Caesar
salad so that they have something to eat
during this long flight and her killer
turns to you and says now what do you
say - Tracey you say Tracey
well serving that chicken Caesar salad
helped Southwest become the low fare
airline because if it's not then we're
not serving a damn chicken caesar salad
and you can see her Kelleher smoking
chains
hooking and drinking wild bourbon while
he says that right he he wants to tell
you that the right simple message can
guide lots of important actions notice
what he's also just told you is that the
customer is not always right not even
close to always right the strategy is
always right the right idea is always
right mission creep is a tremendously
important problem that afflicts the
social sector because the social sector
is filled with needs that need to be met
and so it's easy for organizations over
time to say oh there's good to do here
and there's good to do here and there's
good to do here and we end up with an
organization that is not really doing
the best it could be doing at any of
those things that it's trying to do so
the important point about simple is that
simple overcomes decision paralysis and
one of the things that we should be
doing in our lives and in our
communication and we can be helping the
organizations that we're working with do
is to focus on what's really core to
them
in their mission urban legends are also
unexpected you only use 10% of your
brain I can't figure out any other
reason that that idea circulates other
than it's surprising to people it's kind
of interesting to talk about jaws on a
spaceship there's a planned idea but
it's also unexpected if you'd said jaws
and Bermuda jaws and Hawaii wherever
they didn't film jaws the first time
that wouldn't be unexpected but putting
it on a spaceship that's kind of
interesting I'll teach you to be CEO in
five minutes that's an idea that gets
your attention City Year is an
organization that does national youth
service so they were the basis for the
idea of AmeriCorps that Clinton signed
into signed into law now here's how city
year describes their mission we want to
create the next generation of leaders
for our democracy by bringing together a
diverse group of youth for a year of
national service as mission statements
go that's not bad right I mean we've got
leaders we've got democracy we've got
diversity we've got service those are
all powerful word
and powerful concepts but let's face it
this is exactly the kind of thing that
you would expect City Year to say have
they really grabbed you yet with that
statement here's another thing that they
say we picture a world where one day the
most common question asked of a 17 year
old in this country will be where are
you going to do your year of national
service now that works for me that's a
much more powerful statement because
what they've honed in on is an
unexpected view of what the world could
be like and that's gonna get your
attention much more than the kind of
standard generic sounding mission
statement language that we're all
trained to do in our organizations the
trick to being unexpected is to move
beyond common sense to uncommon sense we
don't need to be spending our time
talking to people about things that are
common sense her Kelleher could have
told you
Southwest is about being the low fare
airline when you say oh yeah herb I've
heard that for years but when he says I
can teach you to be CEO in five minutes
this is it that's the only idea you need
that's moving beyond common sense to
uncommon sense he's highlighting what's
unexpected about his message by perhaps
exaggerating but saying this is so
important if you understand this you're
all the way towards what I do as a CEO
there's another question though is like
unexpected ideas not only get our
attention they keep our attention
conspiracy theories in the natural
environment are great at this
you know gossip about Jennifer Aniston
and Brad Pitt is great at doing this it
maintains our attention for a long
period of time how does that work in
normal organizations
well Sony in 1952 was trying to build an
organization post-world War two so Tokyo
was devastated here's a young
organization being born in Tokyo now
they had a bright group of engineers and
physicists and scientists and the
question is how do you keep that group
of
people motivated in working together in
a potentially demoralizing period here's
the vision that kept them excited for
the first seven to eight years of their
existence as an organization pocketable
radio now to recognize how unexpected
that idea was at the time you have to
remember that radio factories at the
time employed cabinetmakers radios were
pieces of furniture they were not
something that you slip into your pocket
but as soon as you give people that
vision that unexpected vision a really
good scientist would say well that's
interesting you know there's that
transistor technology the Bell Labs just
introduced if we could build something
around that transistor technology maybe
we could shrink the radio down from this
size to this size and once we got it
down to that size so the wheels start to
turn the right unexpected idea can
capture people's attention not just in
the moment but for a long period of time
curiosity gaps hold interest what would
that be like what would it take to get
there what would it take to build a
pocketable radio urban legends are also
very concrete the vanishing hitchhiker
legend that I told you about very often
features the hitchhiker disappears after
running out of the car onto the side of
the road into a cemetery and the driver
of the car finds his or her sweater
draped over a tombstone because earlier
they had passed it across the backseat
of the car to the hitchhiker all right
very concrete visual image there's a
normal engine that's very popular on
college campuses these days about a
kidney theft ring that leaves their
victims floating in a bathtub full of
ice with a note that says call 9-1-1
professional language unfortunately is
not terribly concrete let's think about
the nonprofit sector capacity-building
mission related to forgiving social
enterprise scalability not a concrete
idea among them you're laughing at those
guys and they think about your own
organizations Madison has its own jargon
if you've ever talked to a doctor you
know this here's my favorite idiopathic
cardiomyopathy cardiomyopathy means
something's wrong with your heart
alright idiopathic means we have no clue
what it is now when's the last time you
heard a juicy piece of gossip right
maybe this morning when's the last time
you heard you speak of gossip about a
performance metric
probably never we don't gossip about
abstractions we don't gossip about
numbers we don't gossip about things and
our organizations that are at this very
abstract general level the gossip about
real people doing real things and so if
we want our ideas to stick we better
think about how to make them concrete
let me note that this is the single most
if you forget everything else about what
I tell you this morning this is the
single most useful principle of making
your idea stick is make things as
tangible and concrete as you can let me
give you an example the nature
conservancy in California Nature
Conservancy is interested in preserving
places of ecological significance they
this group in California at one point
was preserving a set of fields in the
middle of the state where there are
these pools that form at certain times
of the year after rainfall and there are
these tiny brine shrimp that arise from
the muck and live and die when the the
pool is decayed but they leave their
their eggs to be reborn this is not
charismatic megafauna this is not pandas
it's not blue whales it's not dolphins
its brine shrimp right but they felt
like it was ecologically important
traditionally the way that the Nature
Conservancy has done this and has become
one of the most successful nonprofit
organizations anywhere by telling donors
you give us money we buy the land and we
protect it
Senay curse is what they call it within
nature conservancy you give us the Bucks
will buy the acres we preserve very
straightforward plan at one point
California did an environmental
assessment in California is this really
unusual place because it spans a great
from a great distance from south to
north
right so lots of temperate distances it
spans a distance from the ocean up into
the mountains so lots of kind of
horrible elevation differences in
climate because of the weather patterns
it's a Mediterranean climate region
which means lots of plants and animals
grow here all those things put together
meant that when they did their
assessment of the state and they colored
in on their map the important areas that
they wanted to preserve that we're
COLLADA CLE central they found that they
had colored in 40% of the state now you
want to do bucks and acres with 40% of
the state of California 9% of it was in
critical danger
so areas around Silicon Valley areas
around Los Angeles that were being kind
of carved up by urban sprawl how do you
even start to motivate an organization
to tackle a challenge like that what the
Nature Conservancy started thinking as
well maybe we can't do bucks and acres
only anymore maybe we better get
involved in policy and setting policy
for how land ought to be used maybe we
oughta be getting involved not in buying
stuff ourselves but in putting together
coalition's who can you know preserve or
deal with things again you're starting
to move your strategy to a much more
abstract level right because no longer
can you have the enthusiasm as an
employee of the Nature Conservancy of I
buy land I take it off the market I
protect it now of a sudden we're putting
together coalition's we're sitting in
Sacramento knocking on legislators doors
trying to make some progress on some
issues how do you make this concrete in
a way that's going to motivate a set of
employees and a set of donors who
historically have given you money
because you buy stuff well how do we set
goals here's one 40 percent we want to
save how about 2% per year for 20 years
break the go down into measurable
subunits it's a little abstract what is
2 percent mean let's make it more
tangible by talking about it
terms of acreage well here it is two
million acres a year anybody have any
clue two million acres a year means it's
it's a lot it's a lot but it's also not
necessarily orienting people to the
right thing I mean it's like telling a
museum director acquire twenty canvases
a year right without regard to the
artist or the time period or the quality
or anything what did the Nature
Conservancy end up doing what they ended
up doing is they start talking about
landscapes there are identifiable blobs
on the map but let's identify those
blobs and start describing them to
people and let's start naming them so
there's an Eric around Silicon Valley
where most of us live those brown hills
that you see on days when you can
actually see the hills around Silicon
Valley
so lots of grass on occasional oak tree
it's called oak savannah not a
tremendously exciting look it's not like
the redwoods
but it's tremendously important in terms
of it serves as the water basin for the
entire Bay Area and it turns out that
it's a unique as a unique series of you
know flora and fauna that live when this
kind of oak savannah what the Nature
Conservancy did is they started talking
about the Mount Hamilton wilderness and
it turns out in that area of those brown
hills there is an area that is the size
of Yosemite that is one of the largest
intact regions that are not subject to
development in the entire state of
California and as soon as they start
talking about the Mount Hamilton
wilderness and describing the flora and
the fauna and why it was important other
environmental groups around the Bay Area
started writing the mouth Hamilton
wilderness into their action plans
Packard Foundation had a lot of money on
the table Greenbelt organizations
started talking about saving the Mount
Hamilton Wheldon's the Nature
Conservancy people said we'd always
laugh when we heard that because we made
this up
but notice what they've done is they
turned an abstract blob of landmass into
an actor
it's the Mount Hamilton wilderness and
by making it that step more concrete
they managed to engage lots of other
people with a idea that is now much
stickier than it was before
urban legends and this is the biggest
stretch urban legends also are in
perverse ways very often credible there
was a story that's circulated in Seattle
in the 1960s so this is the height of
the Cold War there is atomic testing
that is going on in the Pacific Oceans
so we're testing out nuclear weapons and
according to this rumor the fallout from
those atomic tests is being picked up by
the great Pacific trade winds rafting
over the Pacific Ocean and then coming
down and dropping in Seattle all right
that's a pretty scary image and the way
that the rumor said you could verify
this for yourself is that this fallout
is so toxic that it actually pits the
windshields of cars and sure enough
people started looking at their car
windshields and there are these really
tiny hits now it turns out the auto
technology at the time was such that if
you drive your car for a while your
windshield develops tiny pits from
having little dust particles and rocks
and stuff kind of blue but normally
you're looking through your windshield
you're not looking at your windshield
right what's interesting is that urban
legends and rumors regularly of all
these kind of little tests that people
can perform for themselves and in the
book we call those testable credentials
now how is this relevant for you well
let me give you an example from politics
Ronald Reagan in 1980 was running
against the incumbent Jimmy Carter
Ronald Reagan had been governor of
California but he was to a lot of
Americans a fairly scary figure didn't
know if he was a little too conservative
for the country but Jimmy Carter had
presided over for years where we had
substantial domestic problems in
homes domestically it was an era of
stagflation so you hear that term
occasionally these days an area of high
inflation but stagnant growth
unemployment
all right so domestically it looked like
the economy was in tough shape
internationally a very young Ted Koppel
was starting to make his career with a
new show called Nightline that was
counting up the number of days that US
hostages had been held by the
Revolutionary Government in our end
all right so internationally big setback
Ronald Reagan in concluding his debates
with Jimmy Carter could have pointed to
a lot of facts and statistics about the
economy about the position of the United
States in the world
here's how he closed his final speech of
the final debate he said I want you to
ask yourself tonight am I better off
today than I was four years ago now if
your answer to this question is yes then
I think your choice in the election is
clear but if your answer to this
question is no than your choice you have
another choice and I would like to ask
for your vote for President of the
United States notice what he's done he's
out sourced credibility to the viewers
he's given them a testable credential
now if I were trying to improve on what
he did testable credential part is good
I don't like the self-interest part
because it turns out that political
scientists tell us that people actually
don't vote their own personal situation
they don't vote their pocketbooks right
people vote other people's pocketbooks
people both the state of the economy
people vote the status of the the
country right so if Ronald Reagan had
said ask yourself are we better off
today than we were four years ago I
think that would be a complete home run
but notice that what he's done is he's
allowed people to test a claim for
themselves to establish credibility and
the problem is that in a world of spin
people might not believe our facts our
details our authorities and so an
important thing to keep in mind is can I
allow people to test something for
themselves now a lot of times
credibility is about thought well
fundamentally credibility is about
believable
do people believe our message an
important subset of believability is do
people believe that change is possible
and that's a central task of all of the
organizations that you're dealing with
they're tackling big important problems
and the question is do we believe that
big important problems are actually
solvable are they too big here's an
example from bill McDonough as an
architect and designer who's become
famous for claiming that what's good for
the environment can be good for business
now that's pretty unexpected idea it's
not necessarily believable business
people aren't predisposed to believe
that they can do something good for the
environment without absorbing high cost
for their own organization so here's a
story that bill McDonough tells it
describes a Swiss textile firm there's a
high chance that they made the fabrics
that you're sitting on right now but
because of the dyeing process for
fabrics a lot of the chemicals in dyes
are carcinogens lead and Mercury and
nickle and all kinds of things that make
the colors and fabrics and in fact the
Swiss government had declared that the
trimmings of this fabric production
process the trimmings of the bolts of
cloth that Rohnert textile were forming
into furniture had declared that
hazardous waste now bill McDonough says
it doesn't take a genius to realize that
if the trimmings from the bolts of cloth
are hazardous waste but you're selling
what's in the middle
alright you get the idea so runner
textile says we have a problem can you
help us with this so bill McDonough and
his collaborator started out with 8000
chemicals in common use in the fabric
dye industry and they started subjecting
them to a series of screens we don't
want any chemicals with known
carcinogenic process properties
mutagenicity properties they had a bunch
of screens that I can't even pronounce
right but they said we want chemicals
that you could eat and be safe right
they eliminated seven thousand nine
hundred and sixty two but with the
remaining 38 you could die
every color in the spectrum other than
black they started reorganizing the
production process to this chemical
factory around these 38 chemicals the
first savings is that factory workers no
longer had to wear bulky protective
stuff in order to do things the number
of safeguards and checks for the
production process went down
dramatically their cost went down by 15
percent and now instead of declaring the
trimmings hazardous waste Rohnert
textile was able to sell them to
gardeners in switzerland as mulch for
gardens alright so that's pretty nice
Swiss inspectors that came to test the
new factory hooked up their water
testing instruments that detect trace
metals and all those kind of things to
the outflow of the plant I start tapping
on them then they took them and went to
the inflow and plug them in and they're
getting normal Swiss drinking water
readings with normal trace elements of
you know minerals and chemicals and that
kind of stuff the water Factory had
become a water purification plant they
thought their machines were broken
because they couldn't detect even normal
levels of chemicals and minerals in the
eppela bill McDonough says what if
industrial factories can double his
water purification plants note the
specific details that he's just given
you in that stories seven thousand nine
hundred and sixty two failures you can
make every color but like the broken
water meter oh this way
inspectors those add credibility to that
story they're not abstractions they're
not saying you can turn an industrial
chemical plant into a water purification
plant nobody would believe that but
after hearing this story and after
hearing this details were more
predisposed to believe but more
importantly the story as a whole stands
in for what we call in the book of the
Sinatra test after Frank Sinatra's New
York New York if you can make it there
you can make it anywhere right if you
can go into run or textile and make the
changes that you did lower costs turn it
into a water purification plan then
there's hope for a lot of people and so
finding the Sinatra test story for your
organization for your context for your
project may be an important thing to do
enough credibility that they're going to
listen to your message in your plans for
what the organization should be doing
urban legends are also emotional now the
problem is that urban legends tend to
specialize in negative emotions fear
disgust anger what if we wanted more
positive emotions and in particular when
we talk about emotions what we don't
necessarily want to limit ourselves to
is these kind of feelings that we have
like fear or like joy what we're really
talking about is how do we get people to
care that's really the emotion that we
care about it's like how do we want how
do we get people to to well to care one
way or the other about the thing that
we're talking to them about I grew up in
Texas and it turns out that Texas is big
state it has lots of roads and
traditionally the roads have had lots of
litter now how do you get a purchase on
the roadside litter problem in the state
of Texas well the first thing you could
do is you hire a litter researcher and
the little researcher samples random
highways and goes down the highway
clicking clickers for various kinds of
litters there's a fast-food wrapper
there's a snuff can there's a beer can
there's
fast-food rapper and you develop over
time a demographic profile of your
customer and here's your customer 18 to
30 year old truck driving males they
affectionately affectionately called
this person Bubba so here's the question
how do you get Bubba to care about
roadside litter in Texas now there are
two things that you need to know about
Texans that might give you leverage in
this well actually let me pause that for
a second let me give you a couple of
options how do you get Bubba to care
about roadside litter
woodsey out give a hoot don't pollute
it worked for me as a kid alright here's
another option you don't like that one
weeping Native Americans Bubba's like to
make people cry here's another one
fines for roadside litter let's raise
them Bubba doesn't have a lot of pocket
change
there aren't enough police in Texas it
turns out to monitor all the roadways
right so you raise the fine Bubba's
gonna feel like he's getting away with
something bigger it turns out that the
organization that started tackling this
problem put two piles of money of about
the same size aside when they started
tackling this problem one was a pile of
money that was devoted to increasing
enforcement to changing all the signs
that say what roadside fines are putting
more police on the roadways to monitor
stretches that were littered very often
so that's one pool of money the second
pool of money they're going to do put
towards a campaign but we still haven't
gotten a very clear idea of what that
campaign might look like now here are
two things that might help you one is to
realize that Texans are very patriotic
people not necessarily patriotic about
the United States although that is
certainly true but Texas at one point
was its own nation and Texans kind of
think that maybe it should go back to
doing that the rest of the nations kind
of thinks that the second thing that you
have to realize is that Texans believe
that Texas is beautiful
now we're wrong about that but those are
two important facts that this group of
people thought that they could leverage
so here was the campaign that they came
up with don't mess with Texas they would
have country-western music stars we all
know Willie Nelson for the typical Texan
he's gonna stand up and say if you
litter you're messing with Texas don't
mess with Texas you have obscure figures
that most of you might not recognize so
too tall Jones and rainy white longtime
defensive people for the Dallas Cowboys
they stand up and say you mess with
Texas you mess with roadways you're
messing with Texas
don't mess with Texas right so sports
heroes country and western music stars
prototypical Texans telling you if
you're littering on the roads you're
messing with Texas you're messing with
our identity
you're not patriotic all right
how did it work first year the campaign
roadside litter dropped 30 percent
within three years the amount of
roadside litter and dropped 82 percent
and you remember that pool of money that
they had set aside for enforcement they
never spent any of it this was a pure
identity appeal yeah they were the
people that were hiring the ad agency
that came up with this specific campaign
I actually don't know so the point here
is that there are two ways of getting
people to care one is the way that we
were all trained to think about in
business school consequences economics
change the cost and benefits you raise
defines 500 dollars the second route
though and I think this is more
important in a lot of situations is the
identity route you make people care by
tapping into something that they care
about in their picture of themselves
Texas care about being patriotic so tap
into that show them that Texans don't
litter final principle is that urban
legends not surprisingly in a lot of
cases come in the form of stories I do
an exercise in my elective on how to
make ideas stick where I asked MBA
students to make a speech got given one
minute to argue either that property
crime is or isn't a really significant
problem for the United States I give
them some background information from
the Department of Justice it turns out
in the typical speech an NBA can work in
two and a half statistics only one
person in ten tells a story after the
speeches are all done I bring people
back in to the class and I give them an
opportunity to distract themselves by
watching the money Python video they
don't know why I'm playing it but for
about 10 minutes
I'm distract them
and then I asked them what they can
remember of all the speeches that they
just heard in their small group of seven
or eight people and it turns out that
they don't remember very much but if we
extrapolated to a group of 100 listeners
for every statistic that somebody quotes
five people out of a hundred would
remember that statistic sixty people out
of a hundred would remember the story
now I realize the irony of starting to
tell you about stories by quoting a
statistic but I want the right brained
among you to have faith in what I'm
about to say and it's in the context of
a story the World Bank is an
organization that loans out money in
developing nations
they build roadways they build schools
that build water purification plants
those are the loans that they give out
at one point a man named Steve Denning
had made his way up pretty high up in
the World Bank he was running the Africa
portfolio which is about 40% of the
world bank's business but his mentor
left the organization his mentors mentor
that was running the World Bank got
booted on a political struggle and so
it's one of those uncomfortable
organizational situations where your
group that was running the organization
has now turned over and so Steve dinning
is demoted from the head of the Africa
portfolio and told to go off and think
about knowledge management now he says
this is the equivalent of being sent to
corporate sub-area because nobody at the
World Bank cares about knowledge
management we don't do knowledge
management they would tell him when he
went around talk to him we're a bank we
loan money
so here's a problem how do you get
people at the World Bank to start
thinking about knowledge management
because Steve Denning Singh we really do
know lots of things we we not only make
loans we actually watch how those loans
unfold we know what kind of roadway
technology builds effective roads that
hold up over time we know what water
purification plant designs work and
don't work we have a lot of knowledge so
here's a pitch suppose that we were
drowning gave people a definition that
would give their attention about
knowledge management knowledge
management caters to critical issues of
organizational survival adaptation and
change confidence in the face of
increasingly discontinuous change all
right so that's not working for you what
Steve Denning found is that like you
predicted the definitions weren't
working the powerpoints weren't working
people started to pay attention when he
would start throwing in a story and
here's a story in June of 1995 a health
worker in command Zambia logged on to
the CDC website in Atlanta and got the
answer to a question on how to treat
malaria and he would say you know there
are some interesting things about this
story one is that this is not 1999 this
is not the height of the internet the
dot-com boom this is 1995 five years
before the internet was really on
people's radar screens the second thing
to notice is this is not the capital of
Zambia
this is kumano a small town several
hundred miles from the capital and a
third thing to note is that the World
Bank is not in this story the CDC in
Atlanta has its information on the
website so people can benefit from we
know a lot about building roadways and
building water purification plants what
would it be like if we had our
information available to people and we
could leverage the power of our loans by
making sure that people were doing the
right things with the money that we give
them he was called onto the carpet at
one point by the top the new the new
regime the executive team for an you
know
meaning he's given 12 minutes on the
agenda of the day to make his case for
knowledge management and during that he
told this story he said at the break
immediately two members of the Executive
Committee came over to him saying why
are we moving faster on this thing and
they were started reeling off things
that they were gonna go back and doing
in their organization to go in this
knowledge many other trained he said my
first reaction was these people have
stolen my idea I said my second reaction
was how wonderful these people have
stolen my idea notice that there is a
power in that story that did not exist
in the definition you had kind
understand what knowledge management was
already in order to understand the
definition right
but this story suddenly gave you a
little hint of what the world might be
like and Steve Denning wrote a brilliant
book called the springboard story the
springboard is the title of the book and
he talks about springboard stories being
things that give a jumping-off place for
other people to think about their own
issues he said notice that that story
that I told was a bad story I didn't
tell you about the health care worker I
didn't tell you how many kids he or she
had I didn't tell you what they had for
breakfast no details no context no
anything he said there was a reason for
that I didn't want you to be thinking
about my story I wanted you to be
thinking about your story while I was
telling about this health care worker I
wanted you thinking in your own
organization Wow what if we had our
information about roadways up on the web
like the CDC has and a springboard story
he says is mass customization I can tell
one springboard story and in the crowd
of 66 people I've got 66 people spinning
their own story along with it all right
so we're coming to the end of the
presentation so let me just concede that
what I've told you in the last 45
minutes is not rocket science so here's
the question
why are there not more brilliantly
designed idea and here's the punchline
that I anticipated at the start turns
out that there's a phenomena called the
curse of knowledge well researched in
psychology and what it says is that when
we know something very well when we
become experts in a domain and notice
that expertise is good right we come up
with solutions because we're experts the
problem is that when you are experts in
a domain
you immediately become crippled in your
ability to talk about that thing to
others if you've ever talked to a doctor
about anything you've been on the other
side of the curse of knowledge if you've
ever had an IT person come in and try to
tell you what to do with your computer
you've been on the other side of the
curse of knowledge if you've ever talked
to a 12 year old about their favorite
video game you've been on the other side
of the curse of knowledge experts know
what they're doing but because they
think about the world in a more complex
abstract way they have trouble getting
that information across to the rest of
us now notice that systematically
expertise causes problems for us good
communication effective messages sticky
messages are simple experts think in
terms of complexity experts think in
terms of nuance the messages are
concrete well one of the definitional
features of expertise is you think about
the world in a more general abstract
kind of way
good communication comes in the form of
stories but experts spend their time
trying to write the perfect definition
the perfect set of requirements for a
given idea so what all of those things
say is that if we want to make our
messages stick we're going to be in a
position where we have to overcome the
curse of knowledge and the checklist
that we've been talking about may be a
good way to start doing that close with
one final story we we teach at Stanford
a program with national arch strategies
and so we'll go into a community Kansas
City or Cleveland or Miami Fort
Lauderdale and talk to a group of arts
organizations for three days we teach
them a mini strategy course we do
industry analysis we do strategy
statements we do a mission framework and
at the end of the the first day and a
half people take all the spring works
and they apply them to their own
organization and so one of the
organizations that we saw in Miami Fort
Lauderdale was the murid rainout duo
piano group and as part of their mission
statement exercise they were supposed to
write down a Collins and Porras
inspiring purpose statement for their
organization that's going to engage the
motivations of employees it's going to
engage donors it's going to engage
people that might volunteer for them
here's what they had in that box we
exist to protect preserve and promote
the music of duo piano are you inspired
yet alright so people in the crowd
started talking to them about their
organization and these are arts managers
right they're saying not quite getting
it yet why is it important to protect
preserve and promote the music we do a
piano and they said well you know
there's just not a lot of dual piano
music being done any morning and about
that time I
well my mental image adieu a piano was
there are some bars that you can go to
where people come out and bang out show
tunes and you know two pianos and
opposite into the bar and have sing
alongs and that kind of stuff that was
my picture of dual piano and I was
thinking to myself well maybe there is a
reason that dual pianos not being done a
lot anymore so finally one of the arts
people and I couldn't have gotten away
with doing this as a business school
professor why the arts people said look
let me be really blunt like why would
the world be a less rich engaging place
if do a piano music just disappeared off
the face of the earth
and that kind of took them aback and
they started thinking about well how do
we explain this to outsiders and they
said well you know the piano is this
magnificent instrument I mean it was
created to put the entire range and
tonal quality of the whole Orchestra
under the control of one performance and
so when you get two of these magnificent
instruments in the same room and the
performers can build on what each other
are doing and harmonize with each other
it's it's like having the sound of the
orchestra but the intimacy of chamber
music and when they said that everybody
in the room kind of rocked back and for
the first time a group of arts people
thought maybe I need to hear
dual piano music because if dual piano
music disappears I'll never have that
unexpected concrete juxtaposed
experience of having the sound of the
orchestra but the intimacy of chamber
music now why did it take
minutes of relentless and rude
questioning to get a group of people who
had devoted their lines to do a piano to
tell us why we should care about do a
piano and we're back to the curse of
knowledge it's hard to create messages
that stick because in the cases where we
most care about our messages in the
cases where we most have something to
say we are cursed by our knowledge in a
way that prevents us from articulating
that knowledge to other people so it's
hard to create messages that stick next
time I want you to think open legend
style success